hey good morning everybody uh we're
going to be uh going into a caucus both
parties are going to go in the caucus
briefly here and address the bills which
we have on the docket that are scheduled
for today uh if we get through these
bills uh then we will revert back and
take the bills up we didn't accomplished
yesterday um the bills which we have
here today just as a notice there's six
of them which are early bills and we
will be taking action on those today we
have to so we can get those reports put
together and get it all submitted by the
15th so those early bills and if you
have your sheet in front of you the
1288 1305 is not an early Bill 1305
that's the freedom of speech Association
that's not an early bill so we may not
be doing that one today going to take
care of all the early bills which have
those financial notes first
1583 deals with the per pupil cost an
opportunity for an adequate education
that's your base cause that yes we will
be dealing that today 1586 establishing
a foundation opportunity budget yes we
will be dealing with that today uh 1656
adequacy for uh differentiate Aid
special education yes we'll be dealing
with 1656 today 1517 Rel to Statewide
education property tax uh which deals
with the swep uh and gains a chance yes
that is an early Bill we will be taking
care of that today and relative to
requiring excess revenues that yes
that's also a SWAT Bill 1686 we will be
dealing with that today and having to
take action so you can see of those
bills on the docker right there all but
one are early
bills so with that we're happy
Valentine's Day to everybody
yeah I just ordered some flowers for my
Valentine I known her for 9 years
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to take a break for caucus now and
let's take about you know up to a half
hour let's try not to go much farther
than that longer than
that we're going to be in the conference
room right over here so we won't run it
up and down yesterday we're looking for
these guys they're right there up and
down the hallway looking upstairs
everywhere we came out several times
yeah
no
okay the order in which we're going to
take these bills up today are we're
going to take them in sequential order
starting with 1583 moving down the list
and 1288 at the end we are not going to
today so the first bill uh that we'll be
executing is HB
1583 this is relative to the per pupil
cost of an opportunity for an adquate
education I'm going to hand the gavl
over to represent
cordelli thank you Mr chairman um I
would uh uh call on the chair for a
motion on this Bill yes thank you very
much I'd like to recommend OTP for 1583
we'll second that second by
representative luno uh discussion by the
chair yes thank you very much um 14
excuse me
1583 uh has an amendment so at this time
I'd like to uh make a
recommendation uh on uh the amendment
for 1583 as ought to pass as amended and
that bill or amendment number is 0
H I'll second
that discussion it you got
it thank you very much Mr chair
um this is
a an amendment that
replaces the
bill with several components which are
within the education funding formula
currently uh or need to be in the
education funding formula I'll look at
the first part for let on line nine of
the amendment and that just UPS the the
base cost
for uh the adequate education from the
$444 in looking at the formula which
this was constructed from the which was
developed back in
2008 subsequently looked at during
numerous studies specifically the
201718 study the umberger
study and later we have discussed
costing in the the report that came out
in 2020 the commission study what we
recognize here is that the base cost
doesn't reflect that we have right now
the cost the average cost of a starting
teacher within the education
system and that we've done we've
gathered information from the school
district the the 2024 teacher minimum
starting salary in public school
districts and that that minimum starting
be get the proper sheet buried in
paperwork
here
4,2
42,5 so that's where we started out with
that base cost but also we've added in
the 30% for benefit
package and the 20% as has been in the
previous for special
teachers and so what we end up after we
modified all the components within that
formula bringing it up a to a level
which it's approaching what those costs
are today I'm not saying we're there but
it's making a move in the right
direction the the the universal cost
$444 and what we've done is we've taken
grade three and change that to be linked
up with the pupil teacher ratio that's
established for grades K through 2 which
is 25-1 previously the pupil teacher
ratio uh for grade three was 30 to1
grades 3 through 12 so grade three has
been joined in with the K through three
and the intermediate grades and the
middle school grades are are uh
unchanged so that's the change there for
for that portion of the of the bill
there are other portions of the bill
dealing with fiscal capacity
support uh which we have taken the that
concept of needing fiscal capacity
disparity Aid uh from the 2008 study and
we've also took it out of the
recommendations that came out of the
house with hb2 previous year and put
that back in seeing that we don't want
to touch just the left hand side of the
column we want to touch the right hand
side too which provides support to the
communities which need that uh support
to provide the opportunity for an
adequate education it also uh has relief
aid grant as well within that and we're
not touching the hold harmless so that
is is basically an overview a high level
overview of this amendment and I would
hope that we would pass this amendment
and move it on to the proper committees
where further discussion can be had
either through Finance or in some of
these other bills ways and means thank
you very much thank you uh represent
sure thank you very much Mr chair I
believe um representative vlad's um uh
detailed presentation of the um the bill
as amended um accurately reflects the
bipartisan work of the um subcommittee
that was tasked by the speaker's office
to consider school funding and and uh I
appreciate um uh the uh representative
Vlad representative cordelli um
representative dry and others on the um
on the subcommittee that uh that
participated in U in this good work so
much uh discussion from anyone on the
thank you Mr chair and good morning
members of the
committee while I do appreciate the work
that the subcomittee subcommittee did on
this bill and while I I certainly
recognize with the inflationary
environment we're in that there is a
cost increase in
items that said I can't help but look at
spending overall that New Hampshire is
not anywhere near the bottom end of
spending on education in this country
and that if you compare spending in this
country to other Western Nations we seem
to spend an awful lot more on things now
I I can't help but notice that a our uh
jobs that we have in education the rate
at which administrative positions have
expanded compared to teaching positions
is major cause for concern for me and I
think a lot of that has to do with the
fact that we have an awful lot of jobs
and other things that we do solely
because they have become Federal
requirements for us to do these things
so what I see is an awful lot of room
for us to be taking back control of our
education as a state from the federal
government and eliminating a lot of
these costs that are only necessary for
that reason I believe there was a lot of
cost savings already to be found within
our existing system and until we address
that I cannot see reaching deeper into
the taxpayer pocket to do something like
this thank
you further comments anyone um
representative
Damon I would like to say that I
appreciate the efforts of the committee
slask force in this really difficult
project and I don't see this as spending
more money on education I see it as the
state working to make a more balanced
system of Education funding across all
our communities and I support
it repr try thank you
um so I voted against this
recommendation in subcommittee because
uh at the very end of the day a we added
numbers to the fiscal capacity disparity
which I supported and the special ed
which I supported that was for uh free
and reduced lunch and my mind had been
set on 74 million and adding 25 million
from free and reduced lunch put it up to
me what I thought was um a big jump and
I voted no because I wanted to discuss
that before I made a vote on it and that
was and so this is the opportunity to
discuss it and I just wanted to know why
that extra free and reduced Bunch 25
million was added at the very
end uh thank you further comments
representative Pell thank you Mr chair
um yes I will be supporting this as
amended however I want to point out that
we are discussing that our con
discussing our constitutional duty of
funding an adequate education pursuant
to RSA 193 e2a however our local school
district just released their five-year
strategic plan and academics is listed
fourth on the list of priorities out of
a total of four so while I will be
voting in favor the priorities that
Governor Wentworth Regional School
District Define demonstrate that we need
to also hold our local school districts
accountable to their constitutional Duty
education um thank you um further
comments from anybody representative
ladin yeah I'd like to add that the this
bill has two effective dates within
it the fiscal capacity disparity Aid and
the enhanced free and reduced which
totals 64
million is to be instituted July 1 2024
$444 per pupil is due to increase July 1
2025 and that's we're trying to move
into this and and do it
carefully uh we are talking in terms of
dollars here the the increase for the
base cost is a little over $34
million so if you add the the 64 and the
$35 million
together excuse me the 34 you can see
that we're coming up close to 100 th100
million um I believe that this is
revenue that is needed in our districts
to get us to a level where it's
necessary to where we can find people to
teach in education um it takes a an
individual a lot of fortitude to come in
and know that they're going to be
starting out if in a salary that we what
we're paying and some of the if you look
at the starting salaries of some of
those that are on the sheet to come in
we're getting salaries still down in a
30,000
range and that that is pretty Meer for a
young family that has young children uh
it means both have to be working and I
understand that's part of a society
today that really takes two adults in a
family to make it work but I I also
believe that it's necessary to have this
money on the right hand side of the
formula if you plug it all on the left
hand side for the smaller District it
may help some but it's not going to have
the student population to really show
that needed gain that they have and the
responsibilities and the ability to uh
have courses like AP within their their
school but if we put it on the right
hand side we're helping the property
poor communities and those that have
have issues in terms of they're capped
out with Mill rates now which are over
$30 per
thousand some even higher than that if
you take in the Local District the water
district that and that add that in so
there are some districts which are
really tapping people out and can't
there's nothing left so um and I I don't
believe this money that we're providing
in adequacy is being misused there may
be some people thinking that well it's
not the right price priority but that's
a decision that's made by the local
school board thank
you um for the comments uh re cascaden
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to add
that this particular bill again doesn't
quite meet the um the lawsuits that have
occurred in the last three years because
it doesn't fully fund adequacy however
it moves the state in that direction and
because from the numbers that I had
gotten in the subcommittee that there
was a balance of about 145 million in
the education trust
fund adding 99 million of that is very
fiscally responsible in our roles with
the state money as opposed to increasing
an EFA to 500% with no dollar limits so
I think we are being very fiscally
responsible by identifying those
categories uh that are very needed and
it moves us in a Direction of fully
funding and adequate education which is
our
responsibility so I absolutely will
support this and I think it was very uh
well um played out so to speak I mean in
2020 all of the data to support some of
this work occurred during the school
funding commission so we
know sort of our communities we know the
populations in our communities we know
our kids we know how they they perform
we know what equalized valuation of
properties are and we could not be more
fiscally responsible in funding public
education in New Hampshire than moving
this bill forward so I absolutely would
support it I mean I've been fighting
this fight since
2015 um almost 10 years and other people
have been fighting it for 30 years it
really Mak sense thank you represent Lun
thank you very much Mr chair and
um and I know representative lad U had U
had had worked to um to craft this um
the the language here in the amendment
um and uh and I wanted to make sure that
um that one of the intents behind the
amendment
uh didn't accidentally um drop out um
and I think there was an intention that
on on page two of the amendment on lines
29 and 30 you can see how the the um
determination of theed total education
grant includes the two um the two new
components we talked about the the um
the additional um the free and reduce um
the the the um additional free and
reduce price lunch
Grant uh and the fiscal capacity
disparity Grant so those are on lines 29
and 30 and that those additional grants
are not supposed to eat into any hold
harmless that might be in place the hold
hold harmless was put in place in the
last budget as a result of the
elimination of the stabilization the
creation of the extraordinary needs
Grant and those two over time um work
against each other extraordinary needs
increases and and the whole harmless
decreases the the two grants we just
talked about the enhanced free introduce
lunch and the fiscal capacity disparity
are not supposed to decrease the hold
harmless but I'm concerned that um that
in um Section 5 Roman 2 that um on lines
34 and 35 it could be interpreted that
um that that those two additional grants
would eat into a hold harmless Grant I'm
just um I I I I believe our our
Collective tent was for it not to eat
into the hold harmless yeah and if I may
yeah
um the page
three with the
2A uh does speak to hold harmless Grant
and you're you're correct we we did not
want to eat into that area of it so the
intent ah thank you very much thank you
it's there in the Bill thank you very
much you're welcome uh further
discussion
Lakers I just wanted to pass on one
piece of information when we're looking
at what is in the
um
education why does this always happen I
think I
get the education trust fund that
doesn't show up every year it's taken
like four years or more than that to get
to that balance and if we spend that
balance in one year we don't have a
means of making it up and a ways and
means was very concerned about that
because they said we get 30 something I
forget exactly the amount but it was
less than 40 per
year and we're talking about spending it
all in one year and they were like how
are we you know we don't have that money
coming in how are we supposed to do that
when you're talking about an ongoing
expense every year how are we going to
pay that expense when we don't actually
have that money coming into the
education trust fund every
year um thank you I I do believe I might
be mistaken someone could correct me if
I am but I I think I have heard that
based on um current um Revenue that
there is uh projected to be um an even
higher Surplus at the end of the next uh
fund that is
correct any further
discussion follow up followup
representative
lakus but is that because each year we
add some to what we have now or is that
because we are going to be getting
enough
to completely
cover all of this that's the question I
mean even if we are just getting our 30
or 40 each
year that will give us a bigger excess
but it won't give us an ongoing Supply
so that's my
question
right it you we don't exhaust or
hopefully don't exhaust the education
trust fund and so you're right it's only
new revenues coming in but it's built on
the base that we have from the previous
year in the education trust
fund a representative lead and just as a
followup because we've got into the
education trust
fund it's important that we do not drain
the education trust fund we have so many
education my fear is if we drain that
fund the money's going to go off in the
other side of
coin and who knows how that's going to
be spent so uh I think we're prematur
and even thinking at this time that we
should be moving these monies out of
this fund where I I I see my report
right here projected estimated fiscal
year 2025 where there'd be $222 million
in that that fund uh I think it's wise
that we keep there and use it
um I would just comment following on a
few um
and touching on representative Pell's
comments about our local school district
um I think that you know funding is one
aspect of it but leadership is another
um because without the proper leadership
you're not going to get the results in
the school that you want the culture the
academics everything else um and uh to
see that our school district has um
declined in the past two years in terms
of uh Ela
proficiency um but yet they're not going
to address that until the 27 28th school
year is is troubling um so I I think
that we can't look just at funding in
order to improve education in New
Hampshire but um there are many other
factors as um has been touched on
comments Madame clerk I think it's uh
you're
on for the amendment correct Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus
yes representative
Mooney
yes representative Belcher no
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble no
representative
Pell yes Representative corello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell
yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Paul yes representative
baboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 17 y three
Nays uh thank you um I uh looking for a
motion from the chair uh yes thank you
I'd like to uh move otpa for 1583 the a
would be 0620 H I'll second
that okay uh discussion any from the
chair I have no further
discussion representative luno anything
any discussion from the
committee seen none Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
Representative lucus
no representative Mooney yes
representative Belair
no representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble no
representative peternell yes
Representative corello no no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
Nays
okay Minority Report um yeah is there
anybody uh take the gavl back yep I'll
take the gavl back and we'll move down
to the next bill uh that's HB 1586
establishing a foundation opportunity
budget program for funding public
education I Look to represent dry for a
motion sorry what than you 1586
that I'd like to make a motion for
interim
study and I'll second that we have a
motion made to interim study
1586 uh establishing a foundation
opportunity budget program for funding
public education made by representa dry
and second by represent luno represent
dry do you like to speak to your yes I
yes I would thank you um
this is a complicated issue and it's a
different approach to an issue and even
with a subcommittee I don't feel like we
gave it appropriate time to to digest
and analyze um representative leus and I
went through the spreadsheet one time uh
on evening and it took us a long time
just to figure out for one school how
this might apply um and I've feel like
in study is the place to go Rome wasn't
built in a day and um finding changes
for an education funding formula can't
either represent
Luna thanks very much Mr chair I
appreciate representative tr's comments
on that I I concur with with that and uh
and appreciate the the subcommittee's um
uh support for interim study as well so
thank
you is there further discussion from the
committee not seeing any uh Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus y representative
Mooney yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon
no and chairman lad yes 19 y one
day is there any objection to putting
this on
you gipson dry you'll be writing the
report
congratulations
um
um okay the next bill on the docket for
this morning moving down the list
numerically here or sequentially HB
1656 increasing the adequacy grant for
pupil receiving special education
services I'd like to pass the gavl off
to representative cordelli uh thank you
Mr chairman and um I would uh call on
the chairman for a motion uh yes thank
you I'd like to uh recommend
OTP second second by representative
Miler uh
discussion
for a motion yes I I do have a a motion
for an amendment here for 1656 this is
03h and I'd like to recommend that this
OTP uh second seconded by representative
Miler discussion thank you very much uh
the committee which we set up uh this
last several weeks which I feel was a
very productive model for us as a House
of Representatives to follow in the
future where we
integrated folks from
policy from Ways and Means and from
Finance on to that
subcommittee it gave us a greater depth
of understanding the various aspects
associated with all these bills not just
from a policy perspective but where does
the revenue come from uh how does this
integrate with the finance structure
that we have given uh the adequacy
formula and I'd like to thank those
people that were on that all the folks
that were on that committee we had two
from Finance two from Ways and Means and
and we had six from the the policy
committee right here this bill this
amendment addresses the issue that has
come and surfaced in during numerous
studies
that we've had regarding the uh adequacy
portion of our budget that is the
leftand side base cost and the
differentiate Aid
components when we're talking about
special education here we're not talking
about the area of special education
which is addressing catastrophic Aid or
as we call it special education today
that's a different pot of money and a
different very difficult issue which
must be resolved as well what we've done
with the differentiated Aid component
however is we've taken the the uh
differentiate aid for special education
and looked at these 13 different IEP
categories that we have there and we've
looked at the special education
services and support needed for
delivering these uh different uh areas
of special education and in working with
the Department of Education we were able
to better understand how we might weight
out uh by giving a weighted value to the
uh to the category in which a student
may fit into we're talking over 30,000
students here in this state which
receive special education support and I
I we we got specifically the number of
students that entails in each of the
categories we identified three different
categories of special education to wait
out those categories involve let me get
here and are based on the amount of time
that a student is working with during
the day a a and receiving Services
directly associated with special
education the differentiated Aid so we
we've identified three categories
category a b and c category a is those
student students which are inside the
riger class 80% or more of the day and
so they're inside the riger class 80% or
more of the day that means those are the
students that really receive less
service than the student that's let's
say in a residential placement or
receiving uh services for a good part of
the day so is the feeling of the
committee I'm looking for my weighted
sheet
here I have those weights if you want
okay I I I believe it started with like
6 1.2 1.8 yeah correct of the base cost
and what we're trying to do is recognize
that the one shoe fits all right now
formula which we have we have one amount
of money which is allocated for
differentiated for all that's not
adequately meeting the needs of our our
special ed department and and those kids
needing these services so we we've
waited out the first level at one at a 6
$4,044 and we waited out category B and
there's two categories within B and this
is a result of how our information is
reported uh to the federal government
and the Bureau of support special
education support at the Department of
Education has a data fact sheet here I'm
looking at it it's developed around idea
the individual disability educations act
Part B indicator five and it talks about
the education environments how we
approach supporting these students and
they have three categories as I
mentioned a b c and and and and d a b
and c b is broken down into two
categories uh within the federal
reporting inside regular class less than
40% of the day and inside the regular
class 40% % through 79% of the day so
basically what it is it's all those
students receiving 79% on down uh are in
category B and and then category C is
the category where we have homebound
students those which are which are being
Hospital in hospitals those that are in
residential placements those are often
times boarding students and we have
those that are in um separate schooling
situations
and and so
um so the the way it it shakes out is
that I'm looking for my master sheet
here which is of course
buried okay in category
a we have projected for
fy2
24153 students in category B we have
6,193 students students in category C
619 students for a total of
3,965 students that would special
education IEP no I don't know yeah but I
don't the the cost of providing this
program um will increase by
35122 or million so approximately $35
million increases the cost of the to do
this and we think feel it's very
appropriate that we be doing this to
support the needs uh of these students
um and also to to support the local
school districts local school districts
now if they're receiving $2,000
$2,300 approximately for um special
education we are really asking the
school district to pick up a huge burden
especially when you start adding in
catastrophic Aid and when the the
catastrophic Aid doesn't get reimbursed
or start to be reimbursed until after
three and a half times the cost of
educating student that means the local
district has to cough up
$70,000 before they even start to
receive catastrophic or special
education Aid this is a huge burden and
we have to do something to offset these
costs for locals um they're at the point
where um it's not sustainable and we
have an increasing population within
special education so this bill does
address this it's a good move
forward uh especially by integrating the
concept of we ated values for different
levels of IEP this is being done in
multiple States throughout the country
today rather than just having one weight
multiplying that you know you know as a
portion of the base cost um isn't
satisfactory and we are in a minority of
States right now and so uh I I'd like to
recommend that we move forward with this
amendment I apologize for taking so much
time um any further comment from the
second no pleas com
uh representative lakus I see your
hand my comment is really just a I guess
a grammar thing to me the way it's
written and I kept reading it to try to
figure out what it was actually saying
given the percentages that were here it
looks like to me it's saying that the
pupils are receiving special education
services inside regular class 80% or
more of the day as opposed to the pupils
who are receiving special education are
inside regular classes 80% or more of
the day so it actually looks like
they're getting more special services in
a than in B just because of the way it's
worded it and I'm not
sure how to fix it but it looks like
they're receiving special education
Services 80% or more of the
day and and that it's in regular classes
and so can I respond to that I don't
know that's I'll respond to that when we
worked with the director At
Doe uh Miss Bret um this was discussed
and the reporting formula which is sent
out to school
districts and I have the table here
which they receive back it says
specifically category B is broken into
two categories for reporting I think she
was talking about category a and
category a is specifically written
inside the riger class 80% or more of
day and that's for ages 5 through
21 um that's where the majority of the
kids are
so I guess that you know we're trying to
reflect the language which is being used
right now in accordance with the the
procedures at the
department represent follow up please
yes I get that that's that they're
inside regular class 80% or more of the
day but the way it's worded it seems
like they're getting their educa they're
getting special education
services inside that regular class 80%
or more of the day and they're not I
mean some of them are just being pulled
out sometimes they're not getting their
services inside all it just it's just a
grammar issue it's not a what are we
reads differently I think than what
you're I would concur with you um there
there it's something though that this
has to be worked out now you got to
remember the subcommittee had what a
couple weeks to really get on this and
we are using language which was provided
to us by the department in conjunction
with the Federal Form which they have
for
idea I think we're all on the same page
in terms of how to interpret this it
will be going to another committee
obviously so that may be something which
we want to clarify there I think trying
to do it today at this committee knowing
that this has to be out of here just to
the intent is
there um represent D did you have your
hand
up okay representa
Heath thank you Mr chair um I just want
to say thank you um I think this is
sending a signal to our local school
districts that have been spending uh an
excess of 800 million dollars a year on
special education services I think it it
doesn't solve all the issue because I
think we have some federal issues that
we need to take care of as well but I
think it's a beginning and and it sends
a real strong message to our local
taxpayers that we're listening and we're
trying to make a difference thank you
very
much represent
cordello thank you um I have just a
really quick uh solution after a
services on line 15 have a comma and
then the words who are P's receiving
special education services comma who are
inside regular class I don't know if it
was appropriate to say now but I
couldn't help
myself good job the librarian uh
represent
beler thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for the committee uh subcommittee
for working on this I very much
appreciate the intent and I certainly
recognize that we have a very real
problem with issues with funding
especially some of the more catastrophic
instances of of disability at the Town
level I think what we really need to be
doing is figuring out how do we get the
state to fully backtop these localities
when it comes to these catastrophic
cases but we need to do that with that
with 100% making sure we do not create
any perverse incentive toward the
proliferation of IEPs in
general uh the the other thing I want to
speak to on this um is that we've heard
testimony that as of right now money in
the special education fund is not just
being used for students with special
education needs we've heard that there
is money from this program flowing to
mtssb which is a divisive program that
therapeuti all students not just those
who have been identified with a need for
it so as of right now I can't support
across the board increases until we
actually make sure that this fund is not
being turned into a slush fund that it's
being used exclusively for students with
disabilities cuz as of right now I can't
honestly say that if we put this in the
law how much if any of this is going to
be used for students with disabilities
versus being shifted to the mtssb
program I think you might be referring
to another piece of legislation that
we've we've discussed in terms of
special ed uh
funds and not necessarily this bill
representative Draymond
Damon thank you Mr chair I just want to
clarify from my
understanding that the I believe the
number um Mr lad representative lad
quoted was 35 million that is enough to
fund what this amendment proposes to do
with no Pro
rating yes thank
you represent lad I just like to as a
point of
clarification um we've had
previous cases through Claremont and
londondary that the money that's
allocated for
adequacy that's the left hand side of
the column base cost and differentiate
Aid is not
targeted that means it's
unconstitutional for us to say You must
spend this money for this particular
task even though we're saying it's for
elll or we're saying it's a result or
sped or if it's a direct result for the
fnr that's there for poverty it goes
down to the school board to use
hopefully for that task because they're
going to have to pay that money anyways
out to cost out that special education
and right now we know that costs for
special education are
surmounting what we're we're providing
so there's no doubt in my mind this
money is being used for special
education um now catastrophic Aid is a
whole different issue and we do have a
bill which we're going to be coming up
it's not an early Bill the
representative who's sponsoring that
sitting at the table right now and we've
had discussion even just yesterday uh
how we approached that not as a
committee but we had the discussion uh
how to approach this and how to really
get a a study done on on how we're going
to allocate monies that are going to
cover the cost of the as you speak to
represent elure the the catastrophic Aid
issues a huge issue and we have multiple
districts that are shouting about this
one and we need to look at it and it's
my suggestion that I saw a whole lot of
work being done in a short time when we
involved people on a committee that came
in from Ways and Means finance and
policy and hopefully we set up a similar
situation that will move us forward and
come out with that answer that we're all
looking for how how can we help that
District all of a sudden has a kid
walking the door and there's another
$300,000 child that we don't have any
money in any account to to satisfy thank
you repres ter you did you
no okay thank you represent beler thank
you Mr chair and thank you for that
clarification I just wanted to seek one
further piece of clarification I wasn't
on this subcommittee um and as you said
based on the constitutional ruling from
the court we cannot direct adequacy
funds from the state level but is there
any reason that we would have to address
this issue under adequacy as opposed to
under catastrophic Aid where we can
direct those funds just to special
education use and I can respond to that
when we put money out in the
extraordinary needs Grant or some of the
Grant on the right hand side those are
are Grant monies which can have
accountability linked to it and before
we go that that route I think what we
have to do is there there's other means
that we have available to us to really
assess where this money is going
especially I I have real concern about
residential placements out ofate
placements and ensuring that that money
is being used appropriately um and we're
getting the value back for what we're
spending in and the way we really
ascertain that is through the LBA and a
performance audit and that's a huge task
that we have may have to take
represent thank you and that Mak my
question can you give us a status of
subject represent
Casen thank you yes it was um
so this is really a remarkable bill in
terms of telling communities and school
districts that we're paying attention I
mean for anybody to understand that
there is no way this is a slush fun is
you you need to understand what Esa is
of the federal law because there's
criteria for students with disabilities
they aren't just somebody who's not
feeling good that day or somebody who
has an emotional breakdown that's not
necessarily what it is it's very
involved and some of these students
identified are very involved medically
as well um I think it's it's very
remarkable to have uh these categories
that are so important every single
student that qualifies to be identified
and that doesn't necessarily mean a slow
learner a slow learner does not
necessarily meet the criteria to be
identified for a student whoes special
education services but the C ories all
kids need to be in the least restrictive
environment first and these categories
really send a
message that schools need to be set up
to have a variety of programs to Ser as
kids in small groups and large groups
and then the equipment that needs to be
purchased on any given day for any given
student is all based on federal law
requiring a school district to have
these items to have this specialized
staff to have this space so there's a
lot of federal requirements that you
must have and so the
documentation of how these services are
delivered cannot happen without parental
permission at any level and it also
tracks
progress um of students to make sure
that there is always the goal of least
restrictive environment so that the fact
that we have this category ABC and I
think we had looked at at some point at
the education Commission of the 50
states on school
funding and we really really needed to
do something and I just would love to
see this
happen thank you thank you anything for
representative dry thank you for that um
uh discussion I was actually asking like
the LBA audit of things U where the
status of that is that's a report that's
very lengthy report that they do and
they report back to the legislature on
that as far as audits are concerned the
doe2 form does not have to be audited
some school districts I would imagine
the larger ones like a Manchester
certainly audit that form before that
goes out to the to the department uh
smaller districts may not uh but all
districts are required to audit each
year and so they we have a good idea of
how the ass where the assets are where
the revenue where the expenses are
however um we need to get down deeper
into these expenses and we're not
getting all that information so um I I'm
not saying we're going the direction of
the a performance audit but it may lead
to that with some of the issues which
we're dealing with some of those severe
issues of placement outside the
state
yeah anything further from the
committee uh seeing nothing Madam clerk
uh we're on uh amendment 0603 to
1656 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative
leus yes representative Mooney yes
Representative beler no representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pno yes representative cortiella yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y one
day is there a further motion uh
chairman yes I'd like to REM uh
recommend 1656 is otpa with amendment
0603 is there a second second by
represent Aon uh any further discussion
Mr chairman no no seeing anything from
the committee see nothing Madam clerk
otpa on
1656 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Mooney yes Representative beler no
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pel yes representative
Corell yes representative ER yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative Cas Cavin yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y one
nay is the
consent yes okay thank you very much
okay we're going to uh roll on down here
and we're going to be dealing with HP
1517 this is relative to the Statewide
education property tax and excess
chance I Look to uh representative leus
for a
motion I move
OTP is there a second second so we have
a motion made by represent alus as OTP
and second by represented cordelli for
HP
1517 further discussion from the maker
of the
is a a move to take the money extra
money out of the ucation trust fund and
put it in the general fund and this
would be an alternative which would say
take the excess
money um the excess not just what
happens to be in it but over and above
what we normally would get and use it to
directly
reduce taxes on the residents of the
state and I and I see that we come in
all the time we have people please
reduce our taxes our taxes are killing
us property taxes are killing us this is
an opportunity for us to actually reduce
those property taxes by applying that
extra money that may come in from
gambling directly to what a town would
have to pay for swept so instead of
having to pay whatever it is that it's
calculated it would be that much minus
the money that is coming in from this
excess um gambling money so it is a way
I see of directly reducing people's
taxes and I think that is an excellent
thing and I would much rather see that
happen than just put into the general
fund thank you further discussion
representative cordelli thank you I I
agree with the comments of
Representative lakas um just add that uh
during the hearing um the discussion was
of the uh $6.6 million as the base to
determine what was excess uh revenue and
I think that um there was wide agreement
that the next committee could better
look at that $6.6 million to see if that
is in fact the right number thank you
further discuss from represent beler
thank you Mr chair I would tend to agree
with all the previous comments and I'd
just like to add that um this wouldn't
do anything to reduce the fund because
it's only if increases go over the the
certain amount that already exists and
it gives the localities this option that
if they need money for their school for
whatever reason well if we're reducing
the state portion of the swep there's no
reason they couldn't offset that with
the local portion with a Net Zero Effect
that their local taxpayers and recoup
those funds for what they need to do
locally thank you represent
Miler thank you Mr chair I think I made
my position pretty clear uh about my
feelings about games of
chance I'll be voting against this uh
but further in the conversation that we
had uh just the other day with represent
Harrington there was really no uh idea
of exactly what the impact of this would
be there's no data presided other than
the numbers about the 6.6 million we
have no idea what that is we have no
idea what's coming in from uh the gaming
uh program here in the state and I just
think there's a lot of information that
we don't have yet and to pass this on
without having that data is really uh
not very responsible of this committee
and I would urge uh members of the
committee to vote against this
OTP further
discussion represent luno thank you very
much Mr chair so you know we we tried
this experiment for years ago in the
state budget when the uh swept was
reduced by $100 million and
uh pretty much turned out to be a failed
experiment then it didn't really save
anybody um reduce anybody's property
taxes by very much at all but it did put
High demands on um on other Revenue
sources to make up for that difference
in the um education trust fund so uh so
uh I I think for certainly for those
reasons it's been tried before it failed
back then there's no reason to think
this is going to be any
different further discussion question
represent Celli I would just point out
that when um that reduction to swept did
take place there was offsetting funds
identified and that was part of the
calculation and uh part of what was
included in the budget at that point uh
but I would also if I could follow up
with that um to uh just point out that
um we did have a testimony from Dr um
who's here again today um with some
suggestions about how the uh legislation
could be improved and I think um those
certainly should be passed on to the
next
committee further discussion on the bill
represent Miler Andes just to add to my
note should this motion fail I would
move to interim study
this represent
leus I kind of object to the idea that
no savings I think that depends upon
what town you are were in our town di
did actually have a tax savings and our
taxes did actually go down because we
did not choose to take that money and
spend it elsewhere we used it to reduce
our taxes as was the intent and so this
is a local control issue if the
taxpayers decide they're going to use
that money that we give back to spend
elsewhere that's up to them but we have
given them the opportunity to save money
on their taxes and towns did thank you
representative Cordell thank you Mr
chair I just want to go on record um I'm
no fan of gambling um I think it does a
lot of harm to people but the my
supporting this bill is in no way a
support of gambling itself gambling will
go on whether or not we have this bill
um but um it does in a way uh bring some
good out of it and I know um that there
are organizations who benefit greatly
from this uh this sort of charitable
gaming so
okay further discussion representa
Belcher thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to further clarify some of the
information we just heard so with this
bill we we know exactly what the effect
of this bill will be on the education
trust fund because we have those numbers
and it and it isn't to drop beneath a
certain number in the future it's only
things in excess of that so the only
unknown we have with this bill is how
much if any money we will be returning
to taxpayers thank you further
discussion not seeing we have a motion
on the floor the motion is OTP made by
1517 Madam clerk Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Mooney yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 represent Miler I would move to
bill is there a second we have a motion
made by representa Miler and second by
representa Damon to
1517 is there a need for a
caucus are we ready to move on I had a
procedural question I guess it could
apply to everyone not just the caucus if
this was interim studied in our
committee would that impede a
representative from bringing it back to
be reassigned to Ways and Means next
year the an interim study results in in
the study either making a recommendation
that it move forward or not or even
projecting some kind of an amendment to
you know work on it so it wouldn't be
occurring in this bium it be in the next
new legislation submitted in that
November whenever yeah yeah any further
discussion Madam clerk would you please
call the
role Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Mooney no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
cello no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative albone yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10 n motion
please rson merer move to
itl second okay we have a motion made by
represent Miler second by represent luno
itl Miler um I think enough has been
said yeah I we know where we're going
yep ENT luno uh let's give it a drive
okay any further
discussion
okay Madam clerk would you please call
the
role M chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Mooney no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
cello no representative Miler uh yes
representative Cornell yes
representative tenner yes representative
luno representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 yes
10 okay who's going to write the report
I guess I do represent Miler and the
motion will be it it and and your
motions OTP yes okay need those reports
today um we're going to take one more
Bill up before launch and then we'll
break uh and then come back and do the
last one uh HB
1686 Rel to requiring excess Revenue rat
through the Statewide education property
tax to be remitted to the education
trust fund and prohibiting the
Department of Revenue Administration
from setting negative local and County
property um I'm going to hand it off to
you yeah uh thank you and I call on
chairman lad for a motion I I'd
recommend
OTP I'll second
that seconded by representative luno uh
discussion representative lad uh yes uh
I feel that this bill needs to go to
Ways and Means and there's a lot of
issues that I don't think this committee
is uh is not our task uh and it probably
should have been a bill that gone to way
means from the get-go but uh I'm not
going to speak any more to it um that's
just my
slant resident
luno I agree with what representative
lad
said representative uh cascaden thank
you Mr chair um just want to make the
statement that this this bill would be
um a response to the Rand case that was
recently filed and the summary judgment
that was provided and this is showing
the courts and the public that we are
seriously further comment uh represent
dry thank you
uh if this goes to Ways and Means
where's the place maybe this is a better
question where's the place to address
the part about setting negative local
tax rates because we've heard from Dr
that there were some that were not
associated with swept that were
naturally occurring and want to make
forward I why don't you ask for
technical support yeah
um me ask answer one more question
represent lak did you have a separate
question yes different question
yes my question was can we vacate this
directly to
no no it would not be an early bill
because it would not be going to another
committee they would be the committee
and therefore they would have it is an
early bill and we have to get it out of
here by the 15th and there's no I can't
vacate it until we have another session
15th um perhaps the gentleman from uh
Department of Revenue Administration
could come up for some technical
questions um we had one about the uh
negative
tax thank
you and for the record my name is Bruce
canu I'm the supervisor of the municipal
Bureau at the Department of
Revenue
uh representative Tri would you like to
repeat your
question thank you just going back to
what we did in the subcommittee could
you tell us about pleases where there
are negative um tax uh rates set yes um
in a certain sort of touch of irony this
year there were two
municipalities whose Municipal tax
rate um was determined to be negative
because of an excess of
revenues in those
municipalities uh those two uh
municipalities were the identical
municipalities that I found on the
oldest existing records I could find I
believe it was 1975 they also had
negative local Municipal um rates due to
probably the same reason uh the excess
each
followup yes followup would be if if
this bill went through as past you would
be basically
um unable to set a you would not be able
to set a negative local education or
County tax rate to offset other taxes on
Real Property um my my reading of the
bill as written it would preclude
setting any negative rates uh if you
consider your property tax bills we'll
call it the municipal the county the
local school rate and the State
education property tax
rate there would if there would be no
problem to the Department of Revenue it
doesn't pose a problem and we would stop
the calculation at
zero
um what that
means in Practical
terms um I look at it from the
perspective of uh an individual property
tax
bill as you all know I suspect you all
know is that you're looking at a total
rate which is the
combined sum of those four rates well
currently if one of them is negative the
total is going to be lower
if you stop the calculation of an
individual component at zero perforce
the total is going to be
higher I'm a property taxpayer myself
that would mean the tax bill I got would
require me to turn over more dollars to
my
municipality um and then the
municipality knows what it's supposed to
do with the total in terms of getting it
into the hands of of which um
political subdivision is supposed to get
which part of that those dollars but it
would be more
dollars um to the Department of Revenue
um we understand the difference but it's
mere mathematics as we calculate that
total rate and the four normal component
rates uh represent did you have your
hand up yeah yeah I did
um can you just remind me of what the uh
excess swep money would be is that
around $29
million chairman lad I I believe you're
in the neighborhood since we do not
track that we have no need to currently
I don't I don't um keep that number in
the on the top of my head I think that's
what it is little I believe correct yeah
that's anything further from Department
of Revenue ad
Administration seeing nothing thank you
very much for uh providing that
information you're quite welcome uh
further further discussion uh yes
representative but if we passed this and
then it went to ways and means nothing
would prevent them from amending this to
say
minus thing tax
another Comm another committee could
amend it could amend it okay they may
to um if I could just comment uh I will
be um opposing the OTP motion um I I
think that things um have gotten
conflated um in the courts um about
swept um and the uh arguments that it's
unconstitu tional the um
swep is
calculated uniformly and
proportionately which is I think what is
required um under Article 2 Section Five
of the
Constitution the U discussion becomes
the distribution of that money and the
fact that uh some local communities that
collect more than that can keep it
um and I I don't see anything that um in
the Constitution that says that that
cannot happen um you know I I don't want
to play judge but I know I'm contrary to
some uh opinions but I I think that um
and as I have read the London da uh
decision did talk about this and say
that the money should be returned but on
appeal the Supreme Court uh never
endorsed that view uh in the London ter
decision so um I cannot support um this
um this
legislation and uh I I think there might
be others in on the committee who feel
the same way and uh I know the uh State
um is uh actively involved in um in the
rant case as was dis dis uh discussed um
so I don't know uh that when we'll have
a decision by the Supreme Court but um I
cannot uh support this legislation
because uh I disagree with the concept
of uh uh excess swept being returned to
the
anybody represent Miler thank you not
notwithstanding uh the chair's comments
anything further representative
pel coming representing Two Towns who
collect significant amounts of the
Statewide education property tax I'm
will not be supporting this um partly
because for two reasons one is because
I'm concerned about these surrounding
towns that
are we come we have a six town
Cooperative district and I'm concerned
about the other four towns who do not
collect XX swept and how this would
impact their educational opportunities
when we take that money away from them
um the my other concern is that when I
look at our property taxes it's listed
as
Municipal local state and County and
very few people know that we have this
Statewide property tax and have no idea
what excess swept means so when we we're
going to have to go back to the towns
and
explain that two taxes on their tax bill
are actually school taxes and I just I'm
noticing that people don't are not aware
of that and I'm concerned about the
impact and the explanation that goes
along with
that if I could ask um the member a
question um so for those other towns in
our district
you're saying the swept excess from the
Two Towns goes to the education of all
the kids including those other towns
that do not have excess swept is that
correct yes that's what I'm
saying anything further from the Comm
yep represent I'd like to ask then uh
molten bar has an excess of $5.1 million
where does that money
go uh I don't represent molon burough so
I can't answer that question I
understand yours is a little over $3
million
right 1.7 for Wolf burrow
and tufton burrow is
1.39 it's called 1.4 yeah
yep um anything further representative
dry yeah I don't want to keep on the
same subject but I would like to go on
the record is saying is I don't want to
hold up anything because of a negative
tax rate but I would ask the next
committee that um does it on behalf of
those people who might be losing money
further did I see any other hands oh
representative cascaden uh thank you
just wanted to add my two sents of
course New Hampshire has a history of
having Rich towns poor towns not by
anybody's fault we don't have a lake
some people have a lake um and what this
bill does is move that needle so that we
are serving all kids equitably versus
continuing to have Rich towns in poor
towns cuz the people that live in those
towns not their fault they have more
property I mean I have two prisons they
don't P taxes not my fault but we don't
have the opportunity to raise the
revenue that the rich towns have so
you're always going to have Rich towns
poor towns and we saw a lot of studies
and data that kids from disadvantage
communities perform lower on test
scores and it it's a fact um so we have
to think about that do you always want
New Hampshire to have rich town and po
poor towns in terms of how education is
delivered and funded and that's that's a
choice we have to make representative
patrell thank you representative
cascaden would you believe that my
school district has an approximately 30%
free and reduced lunch
rate representative Kaden just to
compare
60% representative
lak I am not sure that the proper term
is Rich towns and poor
towns because just because you have a
lake and if you sold that property it
would be you would be able to sell it
for a bunch it doesn't mean that you
have money it just means that at that
time if you ever sell your home but you
may not that's your home and so you may
have bought that 50 years ago right 40
years ago doesn't mean you have money it
doesn't mean you're rich it just means
that if you were to sell your home that
you live in then you'd have money maybe
and be rich but until then you're
whatever you have and so whatever your
property is valued at doesn't make you
rich or
poor uh just for the record I don't live
on the lake
um and um with my salary here I hear
rich further
comments repr of lad yeah I I think this
can be very divisive I was on the floor
in 2011 when we had this conversation
and it was a good half day
conversation and it it everybody was
digging down inside seeing where they
stood in that one so
um I recognize that folks are going to
be probably voting their conscience on
this one right here I live on a river
and that doesn't really give me a whole
lot the fishing's good in there but I
have five taxes because we also have
amongst the four you mentioned District
tax and so that's the the water system
etc etc so that adds up too so when we
get that mill rate way up in the mid-30s
it's it's tough It's very difficult
especially in a town where we don't have
the industry to back it up or support us
in that the property valuation all so um
V your conscience in this
one anything further I think we've oh
yes represent Tanner okay seeing nothing
further um I think Madame clerk um we
have an ought to pass motion on uh 1686
on the floor Vice chairman cordelli no
represent leus no representative Mooney
no Representative beler no
representative dry
yes representative McDonald
no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
Corell no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner
no representative luno yes
representative Heath yes
representative wock
yes representative Hall yes
representative B
bon no representative cascaden yes
yes ten
10 but a little
different it's scattered isn't it yeah I
have slow down a little
yeah okay a motion a motion yes I would
move
itl
second um I I just hand the back gavel
back over to you at this point with a
new motion yeah who is the second on
that so represent McDonald seconds the
motion made by represent
cordelli
further discussion from the
clerk Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative money yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry no
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes yes
representative Pell yes representative
Corell
yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno
no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Bon
yes Representative cascaden
no sorry very okay uh chairman l
no so now nine nine y
11 N9 y 11
y I need to change my I got
confused okay me too okay all right
that's why I'm pausing okay
okay I didn't know why it
was
study okay so we have no recommendation
here so um is there are there any
subsequent motions to be made on this
study
no there's a move to inter room study uh
the bill with a second from represent
beler
further
discussion well which one represent luno
yeah thanks very much I'm not going to
support the interim study I think this
bill I think this bill needs to um needs
to move to Ways and Means uh and and
have all of its um structural aspect tax
structure aspects of it um considered so
if that takes a um you know a floor
debate to uh to make that happen
then so be it but I'm certainly not
going to support interim study and have
it have it stop here further
discussion represent
Woodcock thank you chairman just to be
clear the our intent the intent of the
the bill we first started was to receive
the bill pass the bill that Ways and
Means correct the bill if there are
errors in there and review the tax
structure that that was the
intent I don't know what everybody's
intent was but my my intent my my intent
was to move the bill to Ways and Means
where that bill could be looked at
thoroughly by the people are experienced
in doing that in terms of the the issues
that it contains however um I also feel
that this is It's times come where
eventually this debate needs to happen
on the house floor um than and so I have
too rationale for where I'm going to go
on this vote I I agree this needs to go
to the floor and we need to have that
debate whether it's a half a day or not
debate represent Bel thank you Mr chair
I just wanted to put forth my two cents
here because obviously this very
contentious the underlying idea of the
bill that's fine but we actually know
that the language in the bill is not
right and that it actually breaks the
existing tax code for a number of our
smaller localities out there and I can't
think I don't think we can go on any
guarantee that this is going to be fixed
if we move on to another committee I
think this legitimately needs to be
studied so it can be fixed so then we
issue I I believe the underlining issue
is are we going to move back to the way
the formula was in
2008 where the money returns to the
state the excess money is not needed for
ad
return and then are redistri distributed
to the towns which have that need uh I
think that's the primary issue the issue
of the negative tax rates I I don't I
think it's a very secondary issue in
regard to where we are with
sweat M Mr chair yes so so thanks and
and when we talk about um distribution
of of State dollars it could be it could
be distributed back to to towns that
that um that that had the the collected
State Property Tax over and above
adequacy maybe in terms of Equitable
grants or something like that so so we
don't know what that what that you know
what the future holds for um uh for
school funding but um uh but uh you know
I think representative Myer said it it's
a it's a state
tax represent k scen u just a a
procedural question so if we wanted this
bill to go to Ways and Means Committee
would we have had to approve the
OTP and that's the only way we can move
it to a way of mean well if you're going
to have it has to pass on the floor if
it's going to have to come out with an
OTP on the floor okay right now it's
going on with no recommendation so we'll
have that no recommendation debate on
the floor yes on the floor have so if we
had voted
OTP with the thought of it moving to
committee would that have prevented the
floor debate no no not necessarily no
okay thanks and and and the floor debate
on the house is going to involve many
more people
engaging in this debate for example
you're going to have the crew from
involved
yeah so we have a motion of interim
study in front of us any more discussion
on the inter room
study Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Mooney yes representative eler yes
representative dry no representative
McDonald
no representative Noble no
representative
Pell yes
representative Corell no representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no Representative bbon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad
no uh five y 15
days so we end up with no recommend
foundation and that's where we
be so
um I guess uh who's going to be doing
the yeah the chair and vice chair
fighting each other out in the floor
that doesn't look good you don't I was
gonna say you don't want to do that no
no no so I'll probably pass it off to
somebody else um but at any rate that's
where we are so we'll have two reports
now we have one other bill we can either
do it now or wait and do it after lunch
and pass I don't I'm looking at the
bills which we did
yesterday and most of them we were
holding for further information I think
all of them that are remain we're
looking for more
information so what we'd have then today
is simply uh
1288 and I don't think I'm prepared to
take up 1305 at this time the freedom of
speech and
bill so did we do all our early b no no
we have not we have
1288 yeah left and what the question is
do we that's the only remaining bill
that's
early that we have an exact we can do it
now or we can take a break and come back
at 1:00 and do it I'm more client want
to take a break here and unless others
are just screaming to get out of
here I don't okay let's let's take a
break and be back here at one o' you
don't have what
weon lunch break okay so that that's
what
e
okay we're going to move forward
here and try to address this last bill I
want to remind everybody that the
reports are due
today as I have to have them
into the people upstairs across to the
clerk by 3:00
today so there's no time to spare so if
you're in
L to write a report it's got to be done
immediately
okay and that includes anybody that's
not done a report from
yesterday's business uh I do have a
checklist for those that I've not
received something but I need to have
that
done so we got to get that into the
calendar as well
you anything before
up if if you haven't gotten it to me I I
will let you know okay good because I
think I'm correct but I don't I think
you are but I'll let you know I'll look
here and and by the way for that means
that the people upstairs have to have
this already by 3:30 that means they
have to transcribe all this stuff so it
really has to be gotten to me right off
the that here we're really under a
timeline
here
one we have I'm think it
today we have 10 bills we have not heard
to date and we have a number of bills we
have to exec still but we're going to be
meeting next week of course that's the
you know president stays off the 19th
we'll meet the 20th the
21st and that's it do we have start time
created not I I I have nothing scheduled
and you won't be exec anything tomorrow
no we're hearing tomorrow morning yeah
yeah yep yeah oh yeah that that's in the
calendar
on so with all this I my sheet for
what's up what are we on 1288
now okay I'd like to go ahead and start
the last exact session for today it's
hb1
1288 relative to establishing due
process rights for students student
organizations and faculty members facing
disciplinary actions by the state
institutions of hired learning hired
learning uh look to represent Bel for a
motion thank you Mr chair I would move
on to pass is there a second second we
have a motion made by represent Belcher
ought to pass and second by represent
cordelli represent beler thank you Mr
chair I would like to forward Amendment
32h and move ought to pass on the
amendment is there an a second to that
second okay I got to find the amendment
here do you have that
amend is that Amendment been shared a
ago what what was the number on the
amendment
you have extra copies I don't have extra
on me there was a ton the other day I
them okay so we have a motion made by
ref represent beler to move Amendment 03
32h is that correct yes that's correct
okay that's one hand out yesterday who
was who made that second on represent
cordelli represent
Belcher thank you Mr chair so uh based
on uh some legitimate uh issues that
were brought up during the hearing we
have made a number of changes to uh
adjust this bill let's walk through and
highlight some of these so in the first
part under disciplinary proceeding um
we've removed
um
reprimand from the uh the definition
there was concern that that was too low
a level at which to initiate due process
protections and we tend to agree with
that it would leave too much open so we
simply remove that so it's only when
there is movement to take action against
um a covered person that due process
protections would then um be
applied uh on line nine we have added
the definition of a criminal allegation
which will come into play we'll I'll
describe on the next page exactly how
that comes into play
later um we have removed the um the
probationary status from the definition
under faculty
member um to make sure that this applies
equally let's see here no changes in
four no changes in five ah six student
organization we have made adjustments to
make clear that this only applies to
student organizations that are in the
process of application uh for
adjudication or appeal so it would not
apply to student organizations that for
instance were denied some time ago or
nature we have uh decided to because
because there is a significant
difference between a professional civil
court context and proceedings that
happen in a college University we have
decided to reverse um in line 26 and 27
the right to infer guilt based on
remaining silent um we believe that
there is no inherent guilt to invoking
your right to remain silent if you're
accused of something um so you should
not they should not be afforded the
uh and the final change here on the
second page of the
amendment yeah it it really speaks to
some of the issues that we've seen uh
both in New Hampshire but also across
the country um where proceedings are
happening simultaneously in a criminal
court and also at a
college it causes a lot of difficulty in
the entire
process uh so we believed it would be
best to under circumstances where
criminal charges are brought against a
student that they be allowed to be
adjudicated in the court system first
before any movement for adjudication by
the college now we don't want to put
colleges in a position where they have
to wait to take disciplinary out action
however so in the meantime based on the
probable cause provided by the criminal
allegation ation is moving forward
colleges can take disciplinary action on
a temporary basis until such a time that
the criminal allegations are resolved in
the Criminal Courts at which point they
can make a determination whether or not
to move forward with their own
college-based um uh process which is
essentially the same thing that
typically happens with civil lawsuits as
well civil lawsuits are typically
something that comes after the criminal
proceedings have been adjudicated and as
a part of this um issue when it comes
comes to uh criminal
charges um there was serious concern
about uh the rules of evidence in a
criminal court and um obviously with the
with the background of Representative
Lynn he he's kind of the expert in the
matter so we decided that it would be
best to really make clear in this that
any adjudication happening at a college
through their process cannot be
admissible as evidence in a criminal
proceeding now what does that mean let's
tear into that just a little bit I want
to clear up any
concerns if a college is in is in
proceeding were they're attributing
guilt or innocence to somebody for
something and there is a line of
questioning in which they uh they
demonstrate that the party was
guilty and then based on that they go
ahead and they find them guilty and they
move forward with discipline now you
would not be bble to admit the finding
of guilt in a criminal proceeding but
there would be no prohibition on
utilizing that same line of
questioning that led to the guilty uh
verdict in the in a court of law so you
can you can pursue the same lines of
evidence you just can't admit the
findings because they're not up to the
level of a civil or Criminal Court when
they're when they're being done uh in a
college
and I'll I'll speak more broadly to the
entire concept because most of the bill
remains Untouched by this amendment most
of the bill is still
there the the point of this is to make
sure that we have basic due proc
protections of floor not a ceiling
afforded to these persons in college and
university systems um I think that's
extremely important these things you
would think they would be protected
based on our constitution our fourth
amendment
the right the rights afforded there but
that hasn't always always been the case
that we have seen so we really want to
make it explicit make it clear that your
fundamental due process protections do
apply when you're being faced with
something that could be life-changing
some kind of accusation in a college I
also want to make clear that while this
touches of a a broad variety of subjects
it is not specific to to any one subject
within the broader field of disciplinary
allegations uh this would apply equally
to plagiarism or
assault if there's going to be action
taken it affords due process protections
which includes very basic fundamental
rights rights that are not just afforded
by our constitution but you can go all
the way back in history and look at
scripture in scripture you will find
things like the right to cross-examine
and confront Witness or an
accuser and we've heard testimony that
sometimes those things are not
necessarily afforded to students
currently in New Hampshire colleges uh
it's it's a fundamentally important
concept for the protection of everyone
involved and the Very legitimacy of the
system itself that we extend these
protections to all of these persons
faculty and students thank you thank you
very much uh representative uh
Tanner thank you um this bill kind of
hit a a nerve with me uh so please
excuse the fact that I'm going to
probably talk about this a little longer
than usual but um I think to to equate
plagiarism with sexual assault um is a
is a false statement a false
equivalency and um this this bill seems
to be uh as was spoken by um one of the
people that testified um partly due to
the fact that you know um during the
Trump era certain Title 9 restrictions
and and procedures were changed uh that
were then um possibly changed back by um
President Biden and that this was to
offset some of those changes into set
into motion um changes that would
prevent New Hampshire from instituting
those changes when we talk about um
sexual assault which is probably the key
key case on campus that this uh bill
would really interfere with um colleges
and and universities all have formal
informal procedures for disciplinary
procedures for dealing with students on
campus and sometimes off- campus and
they also have
me memorandums of understanding with
outside crisis women's crisis groups on
how to handle the different um
situations that arise but in a sexual
assault case and I think you can imagine
the even the court system has certain
restrictions and procedures that in some
way protect the
victim um for example uh you know can
you imagine having a victim of sexual
assault in a disciplinary procedure um
having an open campus trial or an open
campus um meeting uh where the
perpetrator can cross-examine the
victim um can you imagine that they're
allowed to
um uh investigate and
um bring up all kinds of uh information
maybe in the past that's not allowed on
on in a regular court of law um with
these procedures um the disciplinary
procedures on campus there's always the
ability of the person that's being
accused of going into the criminal court
system and when they're in the criminal
court system they have due process and
um so I think I think this this bill
first of all we don't have any major
issues I mean the only issue that we
heard the other day was an off-campus
fraternity house who had an issue with
the local disciplinary system within the
University versus the uh people that
were surrounding this fraternity house
somebody turned them in for having
underage drinking on the on the front
porch or on the lawn um if that's the
only case that we've had in in New
Hampshire that's been a problem um that
people felt they weren't given due
process then I think that's um you know
very small um compared to the trauma um
I worked on on campus for a while on a
campus for a while and actually um saw
some of these couple of um assault cases
and how they were handled through the
disciplinary informal disciplinary
action and I think it was for for the
best for both the victim and and the
person that was accused um and was
resolved on campus um
somewhere up around 80 or 90% of sexual
assaults um on campus are never reported
and a few years ago we had a bill that
required every sexual assault that was
reported either to the health uh place
on campus or to the
um to the dean had to go through
criminal court and we heard from many
crisis centers many victims about how
traumatic that would be if that was
actually put into law because most
sexual assault victims do not want to go
into the criminal system um so I I just
I'm urging you to vote against this bill
um I think it will cause all kinds of
problems on campus um it it takes away
the control that campuses that
University Systems
have um to to deal with their oncampus
issues it would be just like going into
the school system and saying you know
the way that you you you the process you
have dealing with discipline um you know
that we're meddling with that um and we
only do that in really extreme cases so
um there's I've talked to um couple of
people that are involved in colleges and
they say yes this this in fact would
really interrupt and make things very
contentious and very um
traumatic for victims so I urge you to
vote against it thank you further
discussion representative cordelli uh
thank you I just looking at the
amendment I don't see anything in the
amendment that would touch on what um
the representative was just speaking
about Prof
Miler thank you uh Mr chairman I'm going
to vote no on this
and I'll reserve my comments when we
deal with the main
Bill further discussion
representer thank you Mr chair I just
wanted to correct the record because
there was a suggestion that um perhaps I
equated the concept of plagiarism with
sexual assault uh I did no such thing I
would never do something like that if
you ask me the punishment and by the way
this bill does not deal with punishments
it only deals with process if you ask me
about punishment which is where the
equation would be made I would expect
plagiarism would be solved with
something like a civil penalty I think
the death penalty should be instituted
for sexual
assault that said again this does not
deal with punishments it is only about
process and while I hold those things to
be
true I think both persons when accused
should receive full due process
protection because that is how we as a
system as a society as a constitutional
republic adjudicate between guilt and
innocence we have to give people the
chance even if they are accused of
something heinous thank you further
discussion represent
Woodcock thank you chair um just I'm not
disputing um represent of bel's biblical
knowledge but I don't know where
scripture says you have a right to
cross-examine I'm sure you have a a
reference to that you can tell me
offline um but beyond that uh I have a
concern when we looked at the multiple
stages here you had the four-year
college and universities speaking
against this there a two-year College
University speaking against this um from
the day one and someone as
representative Tana said about the
sexual abuse issues we had before when
the bill came about women who were
trying to help particularly women who
were trying to help never was not going
because they're petrified and then I was
looking at the amendment which I uh my
associate here let me to look at uh and
I I still see under one I think it's I
uh the right to the list for five days
you Witnesses the whole thing I see this
is is I understand the procedural piece
but I see it really as um being uh a
limitation I understand the procedure
but it seem a limitation for women
particularly and as a father of a
daughter the last thing I want to do is
put Road M road blocks in her way uh for
her to bring something forward if it
happens so I I I just think this is way
over for what we need I think the colle
in New Hampshire anyhow have been
handling it relatively well um uh and we
heard we've heard very little if any
complaints about the structure between
the four-year college and the two-year
colleges understanding of course that
two-ear college a lot younger youngsters
of students uh I I just uh I think this
is over the top of what we need like a
road we don't need to go down right now
because things there's not an issue to
be solved thank you Mr chair you're
welcome
Rus I know this this bill doesn't
actually say anything about having to
report or any of that which was part of
what rep Tanner was talking about it
doesn't do that it just says
if it's ended up in the system so if
somebody's reported it if they're going
through this is the process that needs
to be followed it doesn't say that the
person the the um victim has to report
anything to begin
with just if it ends up in the criminal
system or in or gets reported and they
are dealing with it this is a process
that you need to follow and um the other
thing saying cross-examine does not
necessarily mean that the individual is
cross-examining often or usually what
happens in court is their lawyer and
their lawyer knows what can and can't be
said
that's all further discussion
representative
beler thank Mr chair I was given the
opportunity so I just like to provide
that reference Proverbs
18:17 the English Standard
Version the one who states his case
first seems right until the other comes
forward and examines him thank
you further discussion represent
Woodcock not biblical iure you Mr chair
um on repr B was discussing the timeline
and collect me if I'm wrong on this
please I may list wrong if if the stud
if student ends up in a procedure
following this process the college May
temporarily invoke something uh and then
it goes to the the criminal court is
running
simultaneously and then after the
criminal court the college may do
something else is that that is that sort
of Bic what you said yes if I may so if
for for instance a student is accused of
assault and there is a criminal charge
brought based on that um they could go
forward with the criminal charges based
on the probable cause provided by that
the college could then Institute
whatever whatever punishment they feel
fitting for that offense on a temporary
basis until the criminal charges are
resolved at which case they could
determine to move forward with their
process I made fall yes so so that's
what I thought it said so my concern is
um I'm accused of doing something it
goes to the criminal court and the call
says you know what boy if we're going to
court we got to stand here be more
conservative I think we're just going to
temporarily suspend you because we don't
dare have you here because you go to
court on this um and then you get the
court and you find out yep nope this was
an error it was an argument we had
nothing to do with anything but this
youngster has already been suspended or
miss school or whatever uh for how long
a time it could be and and most things
in in the state of New Hampshire court
process seem to be extremely slow ver
fast but this could take a long good
semester to get this resolved so a
student a parent the family are all set
aside waiting for for a distri for a uh
opinion from the court and then you
can't go back and fix something when
they're already out of the gate so I I
think that I understand what you're
saying so you're not Double Jeopardy is
type I just feel it's really really
negatively impacts the student and the
family well why is Johnny home I Valley
home or because the school suspended and
because maybe and then oh he's not it's
like you see someone in the newspaper
there's never a not you if it isn't that
small two months
later thank you Mr chair I'm done if I
if I may respond because I think I can I
can speak to that um you thought were
saying yes so you can
wait if I may I I'll respond to that
so there's no perfect solution and
that's why we have this uh this system
of due process in the first place but
what what I can say is regarding
criminal charges um if criminal charges
are to be brought first of all there has
to be an arrest and arrest has to be
based on Reasonable articulable
Suspicion and probable cause then if
charges are going to be brought within
the prosecutor's code of ethics they
have to have a reasonable belief that
they can get a guilty verdict on that so
it's not perfect but it's good and it's
much better than what's currently in
place thank further discussion
represent
Hanner yes I I would um just want to
respond to representative lakis that the
disciplinary procedures usually within a
college they're informal so there's not
lawyers present and you're right in a in
a court of law a prosecutor or a defense
lawyer would know the rules and there
are rules and the process is different
for sexual assault than it is for
everything else and under this
particular bill and maybe representative
belter can correct me but um the accuser
would be able to do the
cross-examination and and be able to
face um his his victim or her
victim thank you I if I'm rep on Miler
and then may I remind the committee we
are focused on the amendment yes we are
not dealing with the bill yet is the
amendment thank you represent belshire
thank you and just to speak to that um
the the answer is the answer is yes uh
the accused would be able to but that's
no different from a court of law when a
person can choose to defend themselves
rather than having an attorney in this
case they could also choose to have an
attorney who would go forward and based
on the information uh Prov you provided
me earlier I can say that the people
involved in the uh adjudication process
themselves have to be trained according
to Title 9 which means they are trained
on adjudication and just like in in a j
just a court a judge would keep the
either defendant or or his attorney in
line when conducting a cross-examination
that that same thing could be in place
here represent
dry thank you
um there's a lot here that I and I may
have missed something but in the
University system of New Hampshire's
notes at the end of the fiscal note it
talked about the statute would pertain
to all proceedings and it said quote
that could result in a reprimand and I
can't find that quote in the bill but
does this amendment take care of their
concern yes thank you that reprimand was
removed it's no longer part of
that further
amendment okay so Madam clerk would you
please pleas call
the it's O it's an amendment for
1288 0332
H Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Mooney yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative mil no repres
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative he no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
Representative bbon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no the
chairman lad yes 10 y 10
days okay the amendment
fails and we're back to the main motion
ought to pass further discussion on the
main MO
yes Pardon Me Oh I thought you said okay
further Bron Miler now thank you Mr
chair I hope the committee can bear with
me a little bit because I've got some
bill did you want to make a motion yes
I'd like the motion to itl this
bill no no wait a minute wait no there
can't be a motion made because we still
have an OTP okay there ISP right yes
sorry sorry it's okay okay that's okay
okay so I've got several issues here
first of all this includes
faculty now I recognize that there may
be some faculty that aren't
unionized but we noted in the testimony
that in at UNH there are four
unions at uh
the Community College there three
unions now you need to realize that
these Collective bargain agreements
basically set out the standards of
behavior and the standards of uh of work
in those collective bargaining units and
believe me I've negotiated these units
of you negotiated grievance procedures
which basically sets out the due process
part so let me explain to you exactly
for those of you that have not been in a
environment let me explain what that
process
is an employee has a right for due
process if they think they've been uh if
the contract has been
violated what that means is that the
employee brings forth to management and
believe me I've been a union rep and
I've been management I've had it on both
sides you bring the issue before
management you try to talk it out and
say Here's the
issues can we resolve this and in most
cases it's resolved at that conversation
level if the employee is not satisfied
with that conversation level and
official grievance is filed a written
grievance is filed stating exactly what
the problem is at that point in time
there's a formal hearing between labor
and management again to try to resolve
it if it's not if it's resolved terrific
if it's not resolved in most cases at
least the ones that I've negotiate
there's a binding arbitration that goes
forward at that point in time it goes
before a neutral third party both sides
present their issues and a binding
decision is made in the
conversation that's the due process that
employees have at this point in
time seven different unions we were
noted in the in the in the testimony
covers Union
employees
next everyone that that was in the room
and I think everybody in this room now
on the committee believes in in the
issue of due
process both UNH and the community
college system provided a detailed
analysis of their due process for
students whether it be in the handbook
whether it be in the code of conduct
whether it be in the uh the the um
employee handbook there's a they laid
the UN said that uh the the um UNH said
that they had 3,000 issues brought
before them last
year all but 80 were
resolved all but 80 were
resolved so the process that they have
Works finally I like to say I asked the
prime sponsor of this bill you may
remember I asked where' this come from
I'm always interested what the intent of
the bill
is and I believe if I you can correct me
if I'm wrong but I think the prime
sponsor said well you know we got issues
nationally he might have mentioned woke
he might have mentioned some cultural
issues we got issues nationally I said
but what's happening in this state what
are the problems in this state and what
was his
response he didn't know any
of so why is this bill before
us we've got the procedures already out
there
folks when you're dealing with a
community like a higher education I'll
just de with higher education here you
try to create a collaborative
environment to resolve these
issues this bill immediately moves it
situation and I don't think that's
healthy in a community now now should
students have their rights their due
process rights
absolutely but I believe that currently
the systems that are in place we've been
over this
before the systems that are in place
provide that opportunity to take place
this is a bill looking for a
problem now one final
say maybe I shouldn't say this but I'm
hyped up so I might as well go for it I
will there's been some biblical
now for some of you the biblical
statements are
dicta for some of us it's a fictional
story so I would refer I would prefer
for my values that we don't make those
again because they what we're dealing
with here are procedures that are
established procedures that have been
worked that have been fine honed that
have provided the right of notice the
right of repeal the right of an
impartial decision maker they are there
now this bill is not
necessary thank you for allowing me to
vent my frustration thank you any
further
discussion represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
and um and I I I agree with with
everything representative Miler uh has
said and I think during his um during
questioning of the bills Prime sponsor
um uh when it was uh when it was clearly
uh uh came out that uh that no the prime
sponsor was not aware of any uh any
significant or or really any problems at
all with respect to the um the um the
due process uh proceedings in any of our
community colleges or university um
system colleges that um that
you know that that really you know for
for us to move forward with something
like this something that's going to cost
the university system millions of
dollars per the fiscal
note to
address to have to redesign reopt rules
going to the Board of Trustees to have
those rules
approved retooling the code of conduct
for students for faculty for visitors on
campus to relearn and retach all of
these
rules and get the practices in place to
employ these
rules is not only a giant
distraction for for two of the country's
best and
finest
public systems for community colleges
and and and
universities but it's a giant waste of
time and it's a giant waste of money um
we have students to educate we have that
that that that come from all across the
state and come from many other states
and many other countries uh and to
completely upend and flip
over these processes that touch every
aspect of the of our colleges and
universities systems operations is just
unbelievable we would have to feel that
we would have to know that something's
going wrong so I've been on The nhti
Advisory board for the last 25 years I
think I'm probably pretty close uh to
that and and I've Jared it for the last
four or five years and during that time
I have never ever ever heard of a single
situation at nhti at any of our
community colleges and I'm also on a
board at the uh at UNH um uh I've never
ever heard of of of any sort of
situation where um where students do
process rights were violated and I'm not
saying that they're that everything at
at um at our colleges every infraction
is minor they're not they're not um
representative Tanner you know said that
that they're not we've seen some
infractions that not only resulted in
sexual assault but also murder of of um
of an individual and and yes that
involved criminal proceedings involved
disciplinary proceedings on campus and
the university system got it right and
to throw it all to tear it all up throw
it all up in the air get rid of 50 years
worth of incremental development and
Improvement of of a system and say you
know what we're going to we're going to
we're going to tear it all up we're
going to we're going to put something
new in and maybe we're going to get
right on it's going to cost millions and
millions of dollars we better be really
really sure that there's a problem in
place but there's no problem in place no
problem uh that that that we can see
right now representative Myer talked
about how how U just in the last year
3,000 complaints um at uh uh at the
University
system almost all of those complaints
were resolved without a hearing 80
resulted in hearings I'm I presume those
were resolved satisfactory
satisfactorily um as well but
[Music]
but what we've got in place right
now is
working and it's meeting the needs of
our students meeting the needs of
faculty and staff and meeting the needs
of the families that that that are that
are public colleges and universities
serve so so to to tear tear it all up at
a cost of millions of dollars when
there's no reason to do so um based on
something that that we have no idea what
sort of disruption it's going to cause
is is I I you know there are words to
describe it not going to use those words
here but but I would encourage everybody
to to vote against the oop pass vote for
an itl and if we cannot get um um uh do
that at least put it off for an interim
study so that we can try to get an idea
as to what these problems are because so
far everybody that's come before this
committee with respect this has had
nothing to say with uh with with about
about current problems or any rationale
for this thank you Mr chair you're
welcome is there any further discussion
represent
cordelli thank you um uh I refer back to
the testimony of um um representative
former Chief Justice uh Lynn
um in relation to uh tearing everything
up and throwing it out um and that he
pointed out on page two this is just the
minimum process that uh would be put in
place in order to protect um the rights
of the accused but also uh of the um the
protections further discussion
represent beler thank you Mr chair I
would Echo uh representative cordell's
comments that this is this is just a
floor and if the college's own processes
through collective bargaining or any
other process are already at this level
not a thing need
change uh beyond that we've heard we've
heard that there were no problems in New
Hampshire but I don't I don't understand
that because we actually heard testimony
of problems in New Hampshire regarding a
lack of due process uneven weights and
measures being applied depending on the
circumstances uh and lastly I would
address the issue of scripture people
can think it's fiction that's fine but
it does establish that the precedent of
cross-examination which was denied we
heard in testimony in at least some
cases is thousands of years old in
Western
culture thousands of years old that
we've been doing this for that long it's
such a core part of our Justice our
concept of due process that we would
allow for that to happen um and as to
the request that I uh no longer ever
cite scripture I would kindly decline
that request thank
Damon I will be voting against this
bill as one of those survivors of
assault I would not have
wanted to follow up what happened to me
sort the way that things are handled as
described
by the UNH and Community College people
presently their
process is what I experienced
and I think it is far more respectful of
both the As salent and the victim than
what is in this uh proposed
legislation any further discussion from
the
committee okay I don't see any further
discussion from the committee the motion
is ought to
pass on
1288 Madam clerk would you please call
the role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Mooney yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Coro yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
tenner no representative Luna no
representative U uh Heath representative
Heath sorry
no Representative wock no representative
Hall no representative bon no
representative C G no representative
Damon no chairman lad yes 10 y 10 n
motion
yes we second that we have a motion on
table to itl the bill made by
representative Miler and second by
represent
luno represent mil do you have further
discussion I think enough's been said
Thank you represent
luno any further discussion from the
committee
when you're ready VI chairman cordelli
no Representative lcus no representative
Mooney no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative peternell no
representative Cora no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Boni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 are there any further
motions do you think there's a shot at
inter room
caucus Alicia you have a
a report from today did you do that okay
see that's what I've been doing the
okay
so we're we're back in in uh business
here
uh there is no desire to go forward with
another Motion in room study so we're we
got no recommendation on that last bill
1288 that's where we stand those OTP and
those itl I'd like to remind folks that
we need these reports right
now and uh for the report is our
recommendation otpa on this pardon me
yes it's otpa okay yeah yeah so we're
not taking any more or motions today and
we're not dealing any more bills so the
executive sessions for for today are
done and complete thank you very much
me so yeah we got to make sure that we
have people not escaping here that are
yeah
okay anyone else need form yeah yeah
forms for sale take this take this back
and give it represent Ry take this and
Jen here's one I is that from the 13th
this